[Music]
stephen has decided to join us he's in
cleveland ohio steven welcome to the
show
hi
so i'll get right to it um currently i'm
26 years old i'm debt free except for my
house i'm currently making
70k a year and contributing 15 to my raw
401k
i'm engaged set to be married in october
my fiance is currently in school getting
a master's
she's going to graduate with about 120k
in student loans
i've been paying her housing and living
expenses for the last two years so i'm a
little
house poor i guess you can say
as we get closer to this wedding october
i'm a little worried about having the
funds ready for a wedding at hyman and i
guess i'm wondering if it's okay to back
off or stop
retirement savings to have the extra
cash for the wedding hmm
so you've been paying her housing bills
for how long
yes uh just under two years now
why
i didn't want her to end up taking more
in student loans
man well that is a it's a bold move for
sure a strange one to be paying
someone's housing bills that you're not
married to
what happens if you if it doesn't work
out would you have any resentment
for paying all the bills we've been
together for eight years now so i guess
i'm you know we're pretty confident okay
well i'll focus on your question here
about how to pay for this wedding is it
all on you guys to pay have you guys had
the conversations with family
yeah so like right now i probably am
maybe like seven or eight short of my
goal and if i was to pause retirement
i'd i'm pretty sure i'd be there
by the time the wedding comes yeah i
mean i'm okay
saving for something like this and
pausing retirement for a short period of
time especially how old are you
26 you're 26. so you're gonna be okay
pausing this thing for a few months to
make sure that we're set for the wedding
uh do you guys have a wedding budget
currently
uh yeah okay
how much is the total
uh the total is right around 30k we got
10 from her parents and i got the rest
okay so 20k is on you and you have how
much save right now
uh just under
14.
okay so you only have six to go then
could you continue to invest and still
have the margin
to save up and pay for this
uh it doesn't look like it i've been
i've been trying to see what else we
could cut back on and is she working it
seems like he's in school no she's not
is she able to
uh no she's going for a med school thing
and she's not allowed to work for her
program
well
this is a it's a tough situation because
i don't like the idea of you continuing
to pay your housing bills even until the
wedding
and i don't really want you to pause
investing i'm okay with it because i
don't want you to go in debt for the
wedding so if this is the only other
option then this is where we're at
how much longer is she going to be in
med school
uh she graduates in august so only like
four or five more months okay and then
she'll have income
yep okay
well here my wedding parameters are this
don't ever spend more than you have in
cash regardless of who's paying for it
and there is no ramsey parameter for
wedding spending but my personal
parameter would be not to spend more
than a third of your gross income if
you're paying for it yourself so in your
case you're putting 20 grand in and you
make 70. so you're not outrageous there
and you've already had the conversations
do you have a checking account that is
just for the wedding budget
yes okay great and you have exactly what
you need in that wedding budget and
you're not going to go over
yeah okay yeah i feel good about this
plan then i don't love it it's not my
favorite plan but if this is where
you're at and you're getting married and
you said october
and it's currently march so we've got
time but i would try to work extra and
try to save so that you don't have to
pause retirement or you can get back to
it real quick i would try to hunker down
get this money saved up keep it aside in
that savings account for the wedding and
then continue investing
okay yeah i guess one other question
with that is i do have a motorcycle
that's paid for it's worth about 10k i
mean i could easily sell that and
probably be clear for the wedding i love
that plan are you willing to sell it
is it going to hurt you emotionally
a little bit but but you have another
vehicle
i do yeah i got two other vehicles
actually
oh wow you've two other vehicles
yep you just love things with motors
don't you i do what does the value of
all those add up to
all the vehicles you have anything with
a motor in it
probably right around 50k yeah that's
too much vehicle when you're making 70.
we say no more than 50 percent should be
tied up and things with motors in it so
yes i'm selling that motorcycle and
congratulations you now have a wedding
fund and you get to keep investing
i got you
that hurt didn't it i can feel it in
your voice you didn't want to hear that
but hey you brought it up man i didn't
know you had a motorcycle you were
keeping secrets from me i didn't know we
had options there's more there's more
motorcycles in the world
exactly and once you get rid of her debt
i would you know what i would do
once you guys become debt free you pay
off that 120 000 in student loans make
it a gift to yourself to save up and get
yourself a motorcycle
if she's okay with it i mean you know
i'm i'm too scared i won't even ride on
the back one of those things behind
james our producer
but you're a brave man cool congrats on
the wedding can i give you a gift
uh sure okay i'm gonna send you uh one
year membership to ramsey plus and i
want you and your fiance to go through
all the financial peace university
videos get on an every dollar budget you
can make a separate one for the wedding
and have one for your life once you
combine your incomes once you're married
but you can go through the videos now
and get on the same page and start to
make a plan for how we're going to pay
off these student loans